The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Actually, two things
to say about eigenvalues.
One is about matrices
in general and then
the second is to focus
on our favorites,
those second derivatives
and second differences.
There's a lot to say
about eigenvalues
but then we'll have
the main ideas.
So the central idea
of course is to find
these special directions and
we expect to find n directions,
n eigenvectors y where
this n by n matrix
is acting like a number in
each of those directions.
So we have this for n
different y's and each one
has its own eigenvalue lambda.
And of course the
eig command in MATLAB
will find the y's
and the lambdas.
So it finds the y's and
the lambdas in a matrix.
So that's what I'm going
to do now, straightforward.
Any time I have n vectors, so
I have n of these y's, I've
n y's and n lambdas.
Well, if you give
me n vectors, I
put them into the
columns of a matrix,
almost without thinking.
So can I just do that?
So there is y_1, the
first eigenvector.
That's y_2 to y_n.
Okay, that's my
eigenvector matrix.
Often I call it S. So
I'll stick with that.
S will be the
eigenvector matrix.
Since these are
eigenvectors I'm going
to multiply that
matrix by A. That
should bring out the key point.
I'm just going to repeat
this, which is one at a time,
by doing them all that once.
So what happens if I multiply
a matrix by a bunch of columns?
Matrix multiplication
is wonderful.
It does the right thing.
It multiplies A times
the first column.
So let's put that there.
A times the first column along
to A times the last column.
Just column by column.
But now we recognize these.
They're special y's.
They're special because
they're eigenvectors.
So this is lambda_1*y_1 along
to that column is lambda_n*y_n.
Right?
Now I've used the fact that
they were eigenvectors.
And now, one final neat step
of matrix multiplication
is to factor out this same
eigenvector matrix again
and realize, and
I'll look at it,
that it's being multiplied
by this diagonal, that's
now a diagonal matrix
of eigenvalues.
So let's just look at
that very last step here.
Here I had the first
column was lambda_1*y_1.
I just want to see,
did I get that right?
If I'm looking at
the first column
where that lambda_1 is sitting,
it's going to multiply y_1
and it'll be all zeroes
below so I'll have
none of the other eigenvectors.
So I'll have lambda_1*y_1,
just what I want.
Got a little squeezed near
the end there, but so let
me write above.
The result is just A times
this eigenvector matrix
that I'm going to
call S equals what?
This is Ay=lambda*y
for all n at once.
A times S is, what
have I got here?
What's this?
That's S. And what's
the other guy?
That's the eigenvalue matrix.
So it's just got n numbers.
They automatically
go on the diagonal
and it gets called
capital Lambda.
Capital Lambda for the matrix,
little lambda for the numbers.
So this is n, this
is all n at once.
Straightforward.
Now I'm going to
assume that I've
got these n eigenvectors,
that I've been able to find
n independent directions.
And almost always, you can.
For every symmetric matrix
you automatically can.
So these y's are
independent directions.
If those are the
columns of a matrix,
yeah, here's a key
question about matrices.
What can I say
about this matrix S
if its n columns
are independent?
Whatever that, you
know, we haven't
focused in careful detail,
but we have an idea.
That means sort of none of them
are combinations of the others.
We really have n
separate directions.
Then that matrix is?
Invertible.
A matrix that's got n
columns, independent,
that's what we're hoping for.
That matrix has an inverse.
We can produce, well all the
good facts about matrices.
This is a square matrix.
So I can invert it if you like.
And I can write A as S lambda.
I'm multiplying on the
right by this S inverse.
And there I have the
diagonalization of a matrix.
The matrix has
been diagonalized.
And what does that mean?
Well this is, of course the
diagonal that we're headed for.
And what it means is that
if I look at my matrix
and I separate out the different
eigendirections, I could say,
that the matrix in
those directions
is just this diagonal matrix.
So that's a short
way of saying it.
Let me just carry
one step further.
What would A squared be?
Well now that I have it in this
cool form, S*lambda*S inverse,
I would multiply two of those
together and what would I
learn?
If I do that multiplication
what comes out?
First an S from here.
And then what?
Lambda squared.
Why lambda squared?
Because in the middle is
the S S inverse that's
giving the identity matrix.
So then the lambda
multiplies the lambda
and now here is S inverse.
Well A squared is S*lambda
squared*S inverse.
What does that tell me in words?
That tells me that the
eigenvectors of A squared are?
The same.
As for A. And it tells me that
the eigenvalues of A squared
are?
The squares.
So I could do this.
Maybe I did it
before, one at a time.
Ay=lambda*y, multiply again by
A. A squared*y is lambda*Ay,
but Ay is lambda*y so I'm
up to lambda squared*y.
You should just see
that when you've
got these directions then
your matrix is really simple.
Effectively it's
a diagonal matrix
in these good directions.
So that just shows one way
of seeing-- And of course
what about A inverse?
We might as well
mention A inverse.
Suppose A is invertible.
Then what do I learn
about A inverse?
Can I just invert that?
I'm just playing
with that formula,
so you'll kind of,
like, get handy with it.
What would the inverse
be if I have three things
in a row multiplied together?
What's the inverse?
So I'm going to take the
inverses in the opposite order,
right?
So the inverse of
that will come first.
So what's that?
Just S. The lambda
in the middle gets
inverted and then
the S at the left,
its inverse comes at the right.
Well what do I learn from that?
I learn that the eigenvector
matrix for A inverse is?
Same thing, again.
Same.
Let me put just "Same".
What's the eigenvalue
matrix for A inverse?
It's the inverse of this guy,
so what does it look like?
It's got one over lambdas.
That's all it says.
The eigenvalues for
A inverse are just
one over the eigenvalues for A.
If that is so, and it can't
be difficult, we could again,
we could prove it sort
of like, one at a time.
This is my starting
point, always.
How would I get to A inverse
now and recover this fact
that the eigenvalues for the
inverse, just turn them up.
If A has an eigenvalue
seven, A inverse
will have an eigenvalue 1/7.
What do I do?
Usually multiply both sides
by something sensible.
Right?
What shall I multiply
both sides by?
A inverse sounds like
a good idea, right.
So I'm multiplying both
sides by A inverse,
so that just leaves y and
here is that number, here
is A inverse times y.
Well, maybe I should
do one more thing.
What else shall I do?
Divide by lambda.
Take that number lambda and
put it over here as one lambda.
Well, just exactly
what we're looking for.
The same y has A
inverse, the same y
as an eigenvector of A
inverse and the eigenvalue
is one over lambda.
Oh, and of course,
I should have said
before I inverted
anything, what should I
have said about the lambdas?
Not zero.
Right?
A zero eigenvalue is a signal
the matrix isn't invertible.
So that's perfect test.
If the matrix is invertible, all
its eigenvalues are not zero.
If it's singular, it's
got a zero eigenvalue.
If a matrix is singular,
then Ay would be 0y for some,
there'd be a vector
that that matrix kills.
If A is not invertible,
there's a reason for it.
It's because it takes
some vector to zero,
and of course, you can't
bring it back to life.
So shall I just
put that up here?
Lambda=0 would tell me I
have a singular matrix.
All lambda not equal
zero would tell me
I have an invertible matrix.
These are straightforward facts.
It's taken down in this row
and it's just really handy
to have up here.
Well now I'm ready to move
toward the specific matrices,
our favorites.
Now, those are symmetric.
So maybe before I
leave this picture,
we better recall what is special
when the matrix is symmetric.
So that's going to
be the next thing.
So if A is symmetric I get
some extra good things.
So let me take instead
of A, I'll use K.
So that'll be my letter
for the best matrices.
So symmetric.
So now what's the deal
with symmetric matrices?
The eigenvalues, the lambdas.
I'll just call them the
lambdas and the y's.
The lambdas are, do you
remember from last time?
If I have a symmetric matrix,
the eigenvalues are all?
Anybody remember?
They're all real numbers.
You can never run into
complex eigenvalues
if you start with
a symmetric matrix.
We didn't prove that but it's
just a few steps like those.
And what about, most
important, what about the y's?
The eigenvectors.
They are, or can be chosen
to be, or whatever, anybody
remember that fact?
These are, like,
the golden facts.
Every sort of bunch of
matrices reveals itself
through what its
eigenvalues are like
and what its
eigenvectors are like.
And the most important class
is symmetric and that reveals
itself through real
eigenvalues and...?
Orthogonal, good.
Orthogonal eigenvectors,
orthogonal.
And in fact, since
I'm an eigenvector,
I can adjust its
length as I like.
Right?
If y is an eigenvector,
11y is an eigenvector
because I would just
multiply both sides by 11.
That whole line of eigenvectors
is getting stretched by lambda.
So what I want to do is
make them unit vectors.
MATLAB will
automatically produce,
eig would automatically
give you vectors that
have been normalized to unit.
Here's something good.
So what does orthogonal mean?
That means that one of them,
the dot product of one of them
with another one is?
Now that's not, I didn't
do the dot product yet.
What symbol do I have to
write on left-hand side?
Well you could say,
just put a dot.
Of course.
But dots are not cool, right?
So maybe I should say
inner product, that's
the more upper-class word.
But I want to use transpose.
So it's the transpose.
That's the dot product.
And that's the test
for perpendicular.
So what's the answer then?
I get a zero if i
is different from j.
If I'm taking two
different eigenvectors
and I take their dot product,
that's what you told me,
they're orthogonal.
And now what if i equals j?
If I'm taking the dot
product with itself,
each eigenvector with itself.
So what does the dot product
of a vector with itself give?
It'll be one because I'm normal.
Exactly.
What it always gives,
the dot product
of a vector with
itself, you just
realize that that'll be
y_1 squared, y_2 squared,
it'll be the length squared.
And here we're making
the length to be one.
Well once again, if
I write something
down like this which
is straightforward
I want to express it
as a matrix statement.
So I want to multiply, it'll
involve my good eigenvector
matrix.
And this will be what?
I want to take all these
dots products at once.
I want to take the dot product
of every y with every other y.
Well here you go.
Just put these guys in the rows,
now that we see that it really
was the transpose
multiplying y, do you
see that that's just done it?
In fact, you'll tell me
what the answer is here.
Don't shout it out, but let's
take it two or three entries
and then you can shout it out.
So what's the (1,
1) entry here of I
guess that's what
we called S. And now
this would be its transpose.
And what I'm saying is if I
take-- Yeah, this is important
because throughout
this course we're
going to be taking A
transpose A, S transpose S,
Q transpose Q,
often, often, often.
So here we got the
first time at it.
So why did I put a zero
there, because it's not it.
What is it?
What is that first entry?
One.
Because that's the row times
the column, that's a one.
And what's the entry next to it?
Zero.
Right? y_1 dot product with
y_2 is, we're saying, zero.
So what matrix have I got here?
I've got the identity.
Because y_2 with y_2 will
put a one there and all
zeroes elsewhere.
Zero, zero.
And y_3 times y_3
will be the one.
I get the identity.
So this is for
symmetric matrices.
In general, we can't expect the
eigenvectors to be orthogonal.
It's these special
ones that are.
But they're so important
that we notice.
Now so this is the
eigenvector matrix
S and this is its transpose.
So I'm saying that for
a symmetric matrix,
S transpose times S is I.
Well that's pretty important.
In fact, that's
important enough that I'm
going to give an
extra name to S,
the eigenvector matrix when it
comes from a symmetric matrix,
when it has a matrix with S
transpose times S equaling
the identity is really
a good matrix to know.
So let's just focus
on those guys.
I can put that up here.
So here's a matrix.
Can I introduce a
different letter than S?
It just helps you to remember
that this remarkable property
is in force.
That we've got it.
So I'm going to call it--
When K is a symmetric matrix,
I'll just repeat that,
then its eigenvector matrix
has this S transpose
times S-- I'm
going to call it Q. I'm going
to call the eigenvectors,
so for this special
situation, A times--
So I'm going to call the
eigenvector matrix Q.
It's the S but it's worth
giving it this special notation
to remind us that this is, so
Q is, an orthogonal matrix.
There's a name for matrices
with this important property.
And there's a letter
Q that everybody uses.
An orthogonal matrix.
And what does that mean?
Means just what we said,
Q transpose times Q
is I. What I've done here
is just giving a special,
introducing a special
letter Q, a special name,
orthogonal matrix for
what we found in the good,
in this-- for eigenvectors
of a symmetric matrix.
And this tells me
one thing more.
Look what's happening here.
Q transpose times Q is
giving the identity.
What does that tell me
about the inverse of Q?
That tells me here some matrix
is multiplying Q and giving I.
So what is this matrix?
What's another name
for this Q transpose?
Is also Q inverse.
Because that's what
defines the inverse matrix,
that times Q should give I.
So Q transpose is Q inverse.
I'm moving along here.
Yes, please.
The question was, shouldn't I
call it an orthonormal matrix?
The answer is yes, I should.
But nobody does.
Dammit!
So I'm stuck with that name.
But orthonormal is
the proper name.
If you call it an
orthonormal matrix,
I'm happy because that's
really the right name
for that matrix, orthonormal.
Because orthogonal would just
mean orthogonal columns but
we've taken this
extra little step
to make all the lengths one.
And then that gives us
this great property.
Q transpose is Q inverse.
Orthogonal matrices
are like rotations.
I better give an example
of an orthogonal matrix.
I'll do it right under here.
Here is an orthogonal matrix.
So what's the point?
It's supposed to be a unit
vector in the first column
so I'll put
cos(theta), sin(theta).
And now what can go
in the second column
of this orthogonal matrix?
It's gotta be a unit vector
again because we've normalized
and it's gotta be, what's the
connection to the first column?
Orthogonal, gotta be orthogonal.
So I just wanted to
put something here
that sum of squares
is one, so I'll
think cos(theta) and
sin(theta) again.
But then I've got to
flip them a little
to make it orthogonal to this.
So if I put minus sin(theta)
there and plus cos(theta) there
that certainly has
length one, good.
And the dot product, can you do
the dot product of that column
with that column?
It's minus sine cosine,
plus sine cosine, zero.
So there is a two
by two, actually
that's a fantastic
building block out of which
you could build many orthogonal
matrices of all sizes.
That's a rotation by theta.
That's a useful matrix to know.
It takes every vector, swings
it around by an angle theta.
What do I mean?
I mean that Qx, Q times a
vector x, rotates x by theta.
Let me put it.
Qx rotates whatever vector x
you give it, you multiply by Q,
it rotates it around by theta,
it doesn't change the length.
So that would be an eigenvector
matrix of a pretty typical two
by two.
I see as I talk
about eigenvectors,
eigenvalues there's
so much to say.
Because everything you know
about a matrix shows up somehow
in its eigenvectors
and eigenvalues
and we're focusing
on symmetric guys.
What happens to this
A=S*lambda*S inverse?
Let's write that again.
Now we've got K. It's
S*lambda*S inverse like any good
diagonalization but now
I'm giving S a new name,
which is what?
Q. because when I give K,
when I use that letter K
I'm thinking symmetric so
I'm in this special situation
of symmetric.
I have the lambda,
the eigenvalue matrix,
and here I have Q inverse.
But there's another
little way to write it
and it's terrifically important
in mechanics and dynamics,
everywhere.
It's simple now.
We know everything.
Q lambda what?
Q transpose.
Do you see the
beauty of that form?
That's called the principal
axis theorem in mechanics.
It's called the spectral
theorem in mathematics.
It's diagonalization, it's
quantum mechanics, everything.
Any time you have
a symmetric matrix
there's the wonderful
statement of how it breaks up
when you look at its
orthonormal eigenvectors
and its real eigenvalues.
Do you see that once again
the symmetry has reappeared
in the three factors?
The symmetry has
reappeared in the fact
that this vector is the
transpose of this one.
We saw that for elimination
when these were triangular.
That makes me remember what
we had in a different context,
in the elimination when things
were triangular we had K=L*D*L
transpose.
I just squeezed that in to ask
you to sort of think of the two
as two wonderful pieces
of linear algebra
in such a perfect
shorthand, perfect notation.
This was triangular
times the pivot matrix
times the upper triangular.
This is orthogonal times
the eigenvalue matrix
times its transpose.
And the key point
here was triangular
and the key point
here is orthogonal.
That took some time,
but it had to be done.
This is the right
way to understand.
That the central theme, it's a
highlight of a linear algebra
course and we just
went straight to it.
And now what I wanted to do
was look now at the special K.
Oh, that's an awful pun.
The special matrices that we
have, so those are n by n.
And as I said last
time, usually it's
not very likely that we
find all the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors of this family
of bigger and bigger matrices.
So now I'm going to
specialize to my n
by n matrix K equals
twos down the diagonal,
minus ones above and
minus ones below.
What are the eigenvalues
of that matrix
and what are the eigenvectors?
How to tackle that?
The best way is the way
we've done with the inverse
and other ways of
understanding K,
was to compare it with
the continuous problem.
So this is a big matrix
which is a second difference
matrix, fixed-fixed.
Everybody remembers that the
boundary conditions associated
with this are fixed-fixed.
I want to ask you to look at
the corresponding differential
equation.
So you may not have
thought about eigenvectors
of differential equations.
And maybe I have to
call them eigenfunctions
but the idea doesn't
change one bit.
So what shall I look at?
K corresponds to what?
Continuous
differential business,
what derivative, what?
So I would like to
look at Ky=lambda*y.
I'm looking for
the y's and lambdas
and the way I'm going to
get them is to look at,
what did you say it was?
K, now I'm going to write down
a differential equation that's
like this but we'll
solve it quickly.
So what will it be?
K is like, tell me again.
Second derivative of y
with respect to x squared.
And there's one more thing
you have to remember.
Minus.
And here we have lambda*y(x).
That's an eigenvalue
and an eigenfunction
that we're looking at for
this differential equation.
Now there's another thing
you have to remember.
And you'll know what it
is and you'll tell me.
I could look for
all the solutions.
Well, let me
momentarily do that.
What functions have minus
the second derivative is
a multiple of the function?
Can you just tell me a few?
Sine and cosine.
I mean this is a fantastic
eigenvalue problem
because its solutions
are sines and cosines.
And of course we could combine
them into exponentials.
We could have sine(omega*x)
or cos(omega*x) or we could
combine those into
e^(i*omega*x),
would be a combination of
those, or e^(-i*omega*x).
Those are combinations of
these, so those are not new.
We've gotten lots
of eigenfunctions.
Oh, for every frequency omega
this solves the equation.
What's the eigenvalue?
If you guess the eigenfunction
you've got the eigenvalue just
by seeing what happens.
So what would the eigenvalue be?
Tell me again.
Omega squared.
Because I take the second
derivative of the sine, that'll
give me the cosine back to the
sine, omega squared comes out,
omega comes out twice.
Comes out with a minus
sign from the cosine
and that minus sign is
just right to make it plus.
Lambda is omega squared.
So omega squared.
All the way of course.
Those are the eigenvalues.
All our differential examples
had something more than just
the differential equation.
What's the additional thing that
a differential equation comes
with?
Boundary conditions.
With boundary conditions.
Otherwise we got too many.
I mean we don't want
all of these guys.
What boundary conditions?
If we're thinking about
K, our boundary conditions
should be fixed and fixed.
So that's the full problem.
This is part of the problem
not just an afterthought.
Now these conditions,
that will be perfect.
Instead of having all
these sines and cosines
we're going to narrow down
to a family that satisfies
the boundary conditions.
First boundary condition is
it has to be zero at x=0.
What does that eliminate now?
Cosines are gone,
keeps the sines.
Cosines are gone by that
first boundary condition.
These are guys that are left.
I won't deal with these at this
point because I'm down to sines
already from one
boundary condition.
And now, the other
The other boundary
condition has to at x=1,
if it's going to work
sin(omega*x) has to be?
Nope, what do I put now?
sin(omega), right? x is one.
I'm plugging in here.
I'm just plugging
in x=1 to satisfy.
And it has to equal zero.
So that means, that
pins down omega.
Doesn't give me just
one omega, well tell me
one omega that's okay then.
The first omega that
occurs to you is?
Pi.
The sine comes back to pi.
So we've got one. y_1.
Our first guy is with
omega=pi is sin(pi*x).
That's our fundamental mode.
That's the number
one eigenfunction.
And it is an eigenfunction,
it satisfies the boundary
condition.
Everybody would know
its picture, just
one arch of the sine function.
And the lambda that
goes with it, lambda_1,
so this is the first
eigenfunction, what's
the first eigenvalue?
Pi squared, right.
Because omega, we took to be pi.
So lambda_1 is pi squared.
We've got one.
We were able to do it
because we could solve
this equation in an easy way.
Ready for a second one?
What will the next one be?
The next eigenfunction it's got
to, whatever its frequency is,
omega, it's got to
have sin(omega)=0.
What's your choice?
2pi.
So the next one is
going to be sin(2pi*x).
And what will be the eigenvalue
that goes with that guy?
lambda_2 will be
omega squared, which
is 2pi squared, 2pi all squared,
so that's four pi squared.
You see the whole list.
The sines with these
correct frequencies
are the eigenfunctions
of the second derivative
with fixed-fixed
boundary conditions.
And this is entirely typical.
We don't have just n of them.
The list goes on forever, right?
The list goes on forever
because we're talking here
about a differential equation.
A differential
equation's somehow
like a matrix of infinite size.
And somehow these sines are the
columns of the infinite size
eigenvector matrix.
And these numbers, pi
squared, four pi squared,
nine pi squared, 16pi
squared are the eigenvalues
of the infinite
eigenvalue matrix.
We got those answers quickly.
And let's just mention that
if I changed to free-fixed
or to free-free I could repeat.
I'd get different y's.
If I have different boundary
conditions I expect to get
different y's.
In fact, what would it look like
if that was y'=0 as the left
end?
What would you expect the
eigenfunctions to look like?
They'd be cosines.
And then we would have to
adjust the omegas to make
them come out right
at the right-hand end.
So this y(0)=0, the
fixed ones gave us sines,
the free ones give us cosines,
the periodic ones if I had
y(0)=y(1) so that I'm
just circling around,
then I would expect these
e^(ikx)'s -- the textbook will,
so I'm in the eigenvalue
section of course,
and the textbook lists
the answers for the other
possibilities.
Let's go with this one.
Because this is the one
that corresponds to K.
We're now ready for
the final moment.
And it is can we guess the
eigenvectors for the matrix?
Now I'm going back to
the matrix question.
And as I say, normally
the answer's no.
Who could guess?
But you can always hope.
You can try.
So what will I try?
Here, let me draw
sin(x), sin(pi*x).
And let me remember
that my matrix K was
a finite difference matrix.
Let's make it four by four.
One, two, three, four let's say.
What would be the
best I could hope for,
for the eigenvector,
the first eigenvector?
I'm hoping that the first
eigenvector of K is very,
very like the
first eigenfunction
in the differential equation,
which was this sin(pi*x),
so that's sin(pi*x).
Well, what do you hope for?
What shall I hope
for as the components
of y_1, the first eigenvector?
It's almost too good.
And as far as I know,
basically it only
happens with these sines
and cosines example.
These heights, I just
picked these, what I might
call samples, of the thing.
Those four values and of course
zero at that end and zero
at that end, so
because K, the matrix K
is building in the fixed-fixed.
These four heights, these four
numbers, those four sines--
In other words, what I hope
is that for Ky=lambda*y,
I hope that y_1, the
first eigenvector,
it'll be sin(pi*x),
but now what is x?
So this is x here
from zero to one.
So what's x there,
there, there and there?
Instead of sin(pi*x),
the whole curve,
I'm picking out
those four samples.
So it'll be the sine
of, what'll it be here?
Pi.
Pi divided by n+1.
Which in my picture
would be, we'll
make it completely explicit.
Five.
It's 1/5 away along.
Maybe I should make these
y's into column vectors
since we're thinking
of them as columns.
So here's y_1.
sin(pi/5), sin(2pi/5),
sin(3pi/5), sin(4pi/5).
That's the first eigenvector.
And it works.
And you could guess
now the general one.
Well when I say it works, I
haven't checked that it works.
I better do that.
But the essential
point is that it works.
I may not even do it today.
So, in fact, tell me
the second eigenvector.
Or tell me the second
eigenfunction over here.
What's the second eigenfunction?
Let me draw it with
this green chalk.
So I'm going to draw y_2.
Now what does y_2
look like? sin(2pi*x).
What's the new picture here?
It goes up.
What does it do?
By here it's got
back, oh no, damn.
I would've been better with
three points in the middle,
but it's correct.
It comes down here.
Right?
That's sin(2pi*x).
That's halfway along.
I'll finish this guy.
This'll be sin(2pi/5),
sin(4pi/5).
See I'm sampling
this same thing.
I'm sampling 2pi*x
at those same points.
sin(6pi/5) and sin(8pi/5).
Maybe let's accept
this as correct.
It really works.
It's the next eigenvector.
And then there's a third one
and then there's a fourth one.
And how many are
there? n usually.
And in my case, what is n in
the picture I've drawn? n here
is four.
One, two, three, four. n is four
in that picture and that means
that I'm dividing by n+1.
That's really sin(pi*h).
You remember I used
h as the step size.
So h is 1/5, 1/(n+1), 1/5.
So it's sin(pi*h), sin(2pi*h),
4pi*h-- 3pi*h, 4pi*h.
Here's 2, sin(2pi*h),
sin(4pi*h), sin(6pi*h),
sin(8pi*h).
So I have two things to do.
One is to remember what is the
remarkable property of these
y's.
So there's a y
that we've guessed.
Right now you're
taking my word for it
that it is the eigenvector
and this is the next one.
I copied them out
of those functions.
And just remind me, what
is it that I'm claiming
to be true about y_1 and y_2.
They are orthogonal,
there are orthogonal.
Well to check that I'd
have to do some trig stuff.
But what I was going to
do was come over here
and say this was a symmetric
differential equation.
We found its eigenfunctions.
What do you think's
up with those?
Those are orthogonal too.
So this would be a
key fact in any sort
of advanced applied math is
that the sine function is
orthogonal to the sin(2x).
That function as
orthogonal to this one.
And actually that's what
makes the whole world
of Fourier series work.
So that was really
a wonderful fact.
That this is orthogonal to this.
Now you may, quite reasonably,
ask what do I mean by that?
What does it mean for two
functions to be orthogonal?
As long as we're getting
all these parallels,
let's get that one too.
I claim that this
function, which is this,
is orthogonal to this function.
What does that mean?
What should these
functions-- Could I write
dot or transpose or something?
But now I'm doing
it for functions.
I just want you to see
the complete analogy.
So for vectors, what did I do?
If I take a dot product I
multiply the first component
times the first component,
second component times
the second, so on, so on.
Now what'll I do for functions?
I multiply sin(pi*x) *
sin(2pi*x) at each x.
Of course I've got a
whole range of x's.
And then what do I do?
I integrate.
I can't add.
I integrate instead.
So I integrate one function
sin(pi*x) against the other
function, sin(2pi*x), dx, and
I integrate from zero to one
and the answer comes out zero.
The answer comes out zero.
The sine functions
are orthogonal.
The sines are
orthogonal functions.
The sine vectors are
orthogonal vectors.
I normalize to length one and
they go right into my Q. So
if I multiply, if I did that
times that, that dot product
would turn out to be zero.
If I had been a
little less ambitious
and taken n to be two
or three or something
we would have seen
it completely.
But maybe doing
with four is okay.
So great lecture
except for that.
Didn't get there.
So Wednesday's lecture is
sort of the bringing all
these pieces together, positive
eigenvalues, positive pivots,
positive definite.
So come on Wednesday please.
Come Wednesday.
And Wednesday
afternoon I'll have
the review session as usual.